let's talk about the embarrassing
reaction from so many defenders of Trump
to the leaked [ __ ] gate audio tapes
Sean Hannity just brushed off Donald
Trump seemingly insatiable II just just
having to have sex with married women
while he's married and grab them by the
[ __ ] noting that many powerful men in
history have exhibited sexual appetites
like none other than our buddy biblical
King David right Sean Hannity take a
look for what it's worth
Hannity is number one wrong about King
David having 500 concubines he only had
two as you can see in 2 Samuel 1516 King
Solomon might be closer with 300
concubines but this is hilarious not
because Sean Hannity is Miss quoting the
Bible I don't really care about that
it's hilarious because this is the one
aspect of King David that people tend
not to defend when using the Bible to
make points or analogies you'll use King
David in many ways to make analogies or
examples but usually you don't talk
about the concubines and Sean Hannity
digging pretty deep to find that as a
reason to defend Donald Trump and then
of course we have Washington State
Republican party chair Susan Hutchison
who had a hilarious and almost brilliant
defense in in terms of how stupid it is
she tweeted Washington she tweeted that
Trump's comments were made when he was a
Democrat this comment gets the gold
medal in mental gymnastics appoint this
woman to White House press secretary if
you win Donald Trump because I've never
heard gymnastics more deserving of a
gold medal than that that's before Trump
called on the Lord was saved and I guess
baptized in what we might call Republic
Christianity or learn the teachings of
supply-side Jesus or how to trickle down
baptism or something of course by this
logic the majority of trumps key moments
in business also happened when he was a
Democrat so those credentials should be
ignored in a value
his candidacy for presidency for
president since he's now a Republican
I've not seen anything like this Pat I
mean this is this is off the wall isn't
it yeah you can tell they're in crisis
mode now and they love to go to the
point that well these are just words
there's no actions behind this we see
more and more of the actions coming out
there's the people from The Apprentice
yeah claiming that he sexually assaulted
them right the women from the beauty
pageant saying that he would kiss them
on not one unwanted there's a lot coming
out about this there's no shortage of
actions that go along with those words
and then lastly this is this is my
favorite clip a trump apologist told
Republican Anna Navarro and Anna Navarro
is is act is really smart I think she's
she's a incredibly bright she was using
the word [ __ ] and Scottie Nell Hughes a
trump supporter said don't use that word
because it's offensive in a discussion
up where she was defending Trump's use
of the word take a look at this video
who has consistently disgusted me from
the first day of this campaign and I
think that every single Republican is
going to have to answer the question
what did you do the day you saw the tape
of this man boasting about grabbing a
woman's [ __ ] all right please stop
saying that word my daughter is
listening when Republicans are shaming
other Republicans on national television
you know things are crazy the
Republicans are completely self
cannibalizing here it is wild and we
will talk a little bit later about the
impact that this is having in the polls
I'm on Twitter at D Pakman it is a huge
huge busy busy news day today and we'll
be here with debate coverage next Omaha
Steaks
sent me a great package of steaks and it
was fantastic as some of the audience
knows my girlfriend is pescetarian so I
invited over some of my meat eating
friends and we used my new grill that I
finally got now that it's almost fall
and everybody loved it it was terrific I
kind of rather grill in the fall than
summer just less oppressively hot
and the limited-time family grill pack
that Omaha Steaks is offering for just
49.99 is a really great way to do it you
will get to filet mignons
to top sirloins for boneless pork chops
for chicken fried steaks a 12 ounce
package of all beef meatballs for Omaha
Steaks burgers for gourmet jumbo Franks
a 16 ounce package of Omaha Steakhouse
fries for caramel apple tartlets Omaha
Steaks
seasoning and for additional Omaha
Steaks burgers and just for my listeners
Omaha Steaks is offering all of this for
only $49.99 this is a huge savings go to
Omaha Steaks dot-com enter my code
Pakman in the search bar and add the
family grill pack to your cart do not
miss this deal visit Omaha Steaks comm
and enter my code Pakman in the search
bar to get over 30 gourmet items for
$49.99